now there's the other side of it and
that's might be the advocacy
part and my group society for academic
freedom and scholarship the scholarship
part
is that we oppose the what we call the
ideological misuse
of of research and teaching
we don't think that students uh
that we don't think it's proper the
students be indoctrinated into any um
uh uh uh lying any any particular
uh political or social views now why do
why do we call that or why do you call
that indoctrination rather than
teaching well it's teaching if uh if if
students are
free to uh uh to object to say otherwise
to
make up their own minds but when there
are social pressures
that one must conform or else
one's grades suffer one's uh social
status suffers whatever
uh then that's then that's verging on
indoctrination
so we oppose the pressure now how do you
oppose social pressure because that
seems like it's difficult to change it
seems almost as difficult to change
as some systemic issues that the radical
left says exists
and that all the issues are or most of
the issues are social
it's always there there's always going
to be some social pressure
we're humans and one thing that we like
is to be included and one thing we
really despise is to be excluded
and sometimes we'll even adapt our
beliefs and values
so that we're included and not excluded
it's there but we can minimize it and
indeed we can become
passionate about being dispassionate
that is we can become passionate about
being open-minded
passionate about governing ourselves by
the evidence
by the arguments and this is what i
think a university
is all about it's a little oasis
where people get together because they
want to understand
how things are in themselves
and they want to look at the evidence
and they want to look at the arguments
and they want to be free to change their
minds to make up their minds for
themselves just on the basis of that
and so as we enter a university students
and professors alike should have a
commitment
to minimize the social pressures to
exclude and include as much as we can